let's talk today about why right wingers
and republicans seem to hate they really
seem furious with electric vehicles and
we've talked about this anecdotally over
the last few weeks there's been these
clips of marjorie taylor greene
making completely incorrect claims about
people are being
enslaved by being forced to get electric
vehicles just completely wacky stuff but
let's actually think it through a little
bit because
when you take it at the top level
you would think that right wingers would
love electric vehicles think about it
they hate and complain all the time
about high gas prices electric vehicles
don't use gas so that would be something
that should appeal to right wingers
right wingers often have this kind of
stereotypical alpha beta male mentality
they see fast cars as indicative of
alpha male status well electric vehicles
are really fast so you'd think that
would be something that would appeal to
them they claim to like self-sufficiency
and not depending on others you can
quite literally charge your electric
vehicle at home
with solar power
harvested
from the solar panels that you own you
don't need anybody else to help you
you'd think that that would appeal to
them you don't need a gas station you
don't need a fuel tanker to deliver the
gas to the gas station
russia can't mess with gas and affect
the gas you get at the gas station think
they would love it and sort of along
that same line i mean
you could end the dependence on foreign
oil as well which is something right
wingers claim to love
but they don't love electric vehicles in
fact they seem to hate them and it's
another one of these examples where you
have their stated principles
and then you have what's politically
convenient or inconvenient and the
reality is
right wingers tend to love oil and gas
fossil fuels they see
burning fossil fuels as a good thing in
many cases
and they like angering people on the
left and so there's a part of this that
is that right wingers want to protect
the established industry of oil and gas
both for its own sake
and to anger liberals and they see
electric vehicles as a threat to fossil
fuels and that's true electric vehicles
are a threat to fossil fuels and that's
a good thing uh you also have you know
the the toyota prius specifically has
become a sort of emblem uh a pro
a microcosm of what the right doesn't
like uh right-wingers often see the
prius as a very beta energy vehicle they
see it as a form of left-wing virtue
signaling now the reality is we are very
much beyond that you can get i mean put
tesla aside you can get a porsche
electric vehicle uh volkswagen audi
hyundai
what's more alpha than a ford f-150
electric which
is sold out until who knows when but the
stereotype remains and it conflicts with
what right-wingers like
you've then got the range issue or the
supposed issue
the right wingers sort of idealizing the
great american road trip they say well
on my electric vehicle i can only go
250 miles on a charge or 275 or 300 or
330 or 370 or soon to be over 400 but
who actually drives that long without
stopping
i mean seriously like if you just on a
normal road trip even if you can fill
your tank with 500 miles worth of
gasoline
who's really driving a full four or 500
miles when's the last time you drove 300
miles without stopping it's not really
an impediment to the great american road
trip the right thinks things that the
left likes must be bad things and since
the left generally speaking likes
electric vehicles
the right ends up having to say that
they are bad and uh
it is a very strange thing
because when you actually go point by
point
they should be loving these electric
vehicles oh and by the way i shouldn't
forget
the electric vehicles don't make the big
boy vroom vroom engine noise
and i think that that's something that
right wingers also don't like so by all
accounts this is something that they
should embrace if they were paying
attention to their principles the
principles go in the toilet as soon as
they conflict with what's politically
convenient and that's exactly what we're
seeing right now